Would you eat a hamburger or a chicken nugget
made of meat grown in a laboratory?
Joshua Tetrick, co-founder and CEO of JUST
is betting that you will.
In tomorrow's world, you can eat more meat,
hopefully safer meat, even better tasting meat,
without eating the animal.
JUST, which is based in San Francisco,
has been producing and selling non animal
versions of food like mayonnaise since 2013
and it's raised more than 310 million dollars
in venture capital.
Tetrick and his team have created products
like JUST Mayo
by identifying plant based alternatives to
common animal products like eggs.
We're one part pharma, one part bio-tech and
a whole bunch of regular food company.
We built a discovery system that has the only
patent in the world
that utilizes machine learning for food ingredient
discovery
and it helped us find this mung bean that
when you put it in a pan scrambles
and that process broken down means that we
source from over 51 countries in the world,
we look at about 21 different molecular properties,
we look at how that bean functions, does it
bake a cake, does it gel in a pan
and then we see if it makes ice cream or butter
or scrambled eggs.
Our process of finding these new tools is
high tech, but what we find is not high tech at all.
The mung bean has been in the world's food
system for 4400 years.
I sure as hell didn't invent the mung bean.
JUST is one of a handful of tech companies
working to disrupt the meat production industry.
While many of it's competitors are pursuing
better plant based meat substitutes,
JUST is pushing ahead with so called clean
meat or lab grown animal tissue
that requires no farming, no feeding of livestock
and no slaughterhouses.
Only a single sample from a single animal
duplicated endlessly.
JUST and companies like it are poised to disrupt
the entire livestock industry
but the established players are turning to
the government to protect their turf.
The United States Cattlemen's Association,
which declined to participate in this story,
submitted a petition still under consideration
by the United States Department of Agriculture
asking that the words meat and beef exclude
any products
that are 'neither derived from animals, nor slaughtered
in the traditional manner.'
The power of the terms is a lot more powerful
than people think, especially in food.
Imagine Tesla launches a pickup truck, but
US Department of Transportation says
'Hold up, Tesla, Elon, you can't call it a
pickup truck.'
You have to call it electric mobility transport
unit.
That's not winning in Alabama, even though
it might be fast,
even though it might have an amazing amount
of horsepower,
because a car is identity, but food's identity
even more.
JUST is also looking to transcend the vegan
vs carnivore paradigm.
We don't allow the term vegan to be used in
our company.
Not because we don't believe in the spirit
of it,
that word ends up turning off 99% of people.
The food system needs to start over,
little girls in the second row of a class
in Liberia aren't getting proper nutrients,
a young boy growing up in Birmingham Alabama
is accelerating a path to Type 2 diabetes,
animals are being confined in needless ways,
it's contributing to climate change,
and I think if we can think differently about
the food system
while also realizing that we can't be so new
and so out there
that it doesn't relate to the everyday human
being, we can do a whole lot of good.
And that's what I want to do.
This isn't Tetrick's first fight with entrenched
food interests.
JUST Mayo has been threatened by the Egg Board,
I can't believe this.
When the company's first product, JUST Mayo,
appeared on the shelves of major retailers
the American Egg Board went on the attack.
It tried and failed to get Whole Foods to
pull the product from it's shelves
and hired a network of writers to trash the
product on food review sites.
Target pulled JUST Mayo off it's shelves after
receiving an anonymous letter about food safety
but an FDA investigation later found that
the product was safe.
And investigators failed to ever identify
the author of the letter.
At one point Egg Board members even discussed
putting out a hit on Tetrick
with one writing that he should have his old
buddies from Brooklyn pay him a visit.
The officials claimed to be joking.
I think the email where they discussed putting
a hit out on me,
where the American Egg Board discusses that
was probably the most surprising.
I mean, hell, at the time we probably had
15-20 people in the company
I really didn't know what the hell I was doing.
And all of a sudden the egg industry has an
interest in this little mayo product.
And when bigger more entrenched folks pay
attention,
maybe it's validating that you're on to something.
Whether or not consumers are ready for lab
grown meat is yet to be seen.
And the company landed in hot water with the
SEC in 2016
after being accused of buying it's own products
off the shelves
to boost sales figures to raise more venture
capital.
Though the company claims it was a quality
control measure
and no charges resulted in the investigation.
But with JUST products in more than 20,000
stores
and plans to release lab grown clean meat
onto the market by the end of the year
at a retail price within 30% of that of traditional
meat
Tetrick is optimistic about the future of
his company and the global food system.
It was an out of body experience to sit there
and eat a chicken
but have the chicken that you're eating running
around in front of you.
We're working on chicken nuggets, maybe fois
gras.
I want to focus less on changing the cultural
and societal perceptions of a word,
I don't know how long that's gonna take,
and more on feed as many people as I can
every day a little bit better.